You still see her sometimes, don't you?
Your sister?
No, sweetheart.
Not for a very long time.
I saw her again the other day.
It was her. I know it.
You really want me to believe that that's her?
You don't see the resemblance?
To a dead four-year-old girl? No.
I saw the way you looked at her.
I saw you! Mom!
You more than anyone..
You have to believe!
I really think you need to let this go now.
Your sister was a very old soul.
Sometimes we just don't come back.
I don't know how to fix this.
I don't know...
if there is any way to fix this anymore.
I wish you were here...
because I think you'd know what to do.
And I think I'd listen to you.
I think you're the only one I'd listen to.
But...
you're not here.
I missed you.